la situation est en train de s'aggraver
sur le front de l'épidémie madame la
députée pour être tout à fait franc avec
vous aujourd'hui santé publique france
publiera les chiffres comme chaque jour
des contaminations de la veille et nous
déplorons 47000 contamination au cours
des 24 dernières heures ce qui continue
de marquer une augmentation la diffusion
du virus sur le territoire national sur
tout le territoire national avec une
moyenne du nombre de contaminations par
jour qui dépasse les 30 mille et qui
pourrait être si l'on suivait cette
dynamique de plus 60% par semaine
supérieurs aux pics de la troisième
vague d'ici à la fin de la semaine